[Music]
hello everyone
uh so in the previous class we had
uh we had discussed the cautious formula
and we had discussed a few important
things uh associated
with uh with the various stress
components
now today we are going to discuss
something very very important we are not
going to prove it formally
but we are just going to mention it so
all this while we have been dealing with
the balance of linear momentum so what
happens if we use
the balance of angular momentum so
if we do the balance
of angular momentum
for the special case where there are no
body couples
to consider
when no body couples are present
so just like you can have body forces
you can also have
a distribution of body couples in in
certain special applications
but we will be solely concerned with
those applications
where there are no body couples so in
this
uh very special scenario but very very
common
like like it is it is the exception
that body couples would exist okay so
it is the more far more common
engineering scenario
that you will have uh no existence of
body couples and in that case if you
carry out the balance
of angular momentum and we are not going
to carry out
the steps like we had done in the case
of the balance of linear momentum
so if we carry forward all those steps
what we are going to get
is is this conclusion
that the stress tensor
is going to be is going to come out to
be symmetric
so this is the conclusion that we obtain
from the balance of angular momentum it
seems a little bit weird that we are
dealing with the balance of angular
momentum and how come this
arises but uh you can
actually go forward with the entire
steps but in the interest of time we'll
not do that
so this is the important conclusion that
we want to have and this is very very
important like
you need to remember this all throughout
that the stress tensor is symmetric
basically what this means is that
sigma 1 2 is equal to
sigma 2 1 sigma
2 3 is equal to sigma 3
2 and
sigma 1 3 is equal to sigma
3 1.
okay uh i believe
uh most of you are uh already familiar
with this
uh in the form that you came across in
your first year mechanics
where you said that tau xy is equal to
tau y x
y z is equal to tau z y and tau x z
is equal to tau zx so in the same way
that you were using for the shear
stresses
the taus the greek symbol tau uh we are
no longer using that greek symbol tau we
are just keeping all the stress
components
uh to be denoted by the same greek
symbol sigma
it is the index the subscript present
which will
indicate whether it is the normal
component or the shear component
and we are going to discuss the normal
and the shear components
of stresses uh in a subsequent lecture
uh in a far more elaborate fashion
but for now we just mention it in
passing
now what happens if we actually utilize
this
uh this new conclusion that the stress
tensor is symmetric
so if we go back to the previous slide
we'll see that we had this relation
this is the famous cautious formula or
relation
or stress theorem and
uh it is in this particular form
uh written in the vector or compact
notation
so if we uh if we use this
what we obtain is simply
that the relation
is absolutely equivalent
to this please note that time and again
i am writing this sigma in the compact
notation
with a double tilde beneath it the
double tilde beneath it
is just a mathematical way of
representing that this is a tensor of
order two
so you may say that if that is so
then shouldn't a vector be represented
by
it by a single tilde and that is very
much true
there are many many people who do
represent the
the vector not by this kind of a half
arrow on top of the
letter instead by a single tilde at the
bottom
but that is more common among
mathematicians
uh as engineers it is far more common
for us to write the
vector with the half arrow symbol and
will stick to that convention
okay now uh what is the use of all of
these things
it is good to know that the cautious
formula can be written in this
alternative fashion
uh exploiting the symmetry of the stress
tensor
uh but what if we we
we want to utilize this back in the
equation or the balance of linear
momentum
so let us go back and take a look once
more at that equation
so we had this nice form
for the balance of linear momentum
now what we want to do is we want to
substitute
the form that we just obtained for the
traction vector
that is this vector in terms of the
stress components that is the sigma dot
n and we want to proceed from there so
what is the motivation why do we want to
do this
so uh it should not be like an arbitrary
set of steps
that we are doing just because we can
there should be a certain
proper motivation for doing certain
things so
the motivation is like this
you see on the left hand side what we
have here
is basically a volume integral okay
so this is a volume integral on the left
hand side and this is a surface integral
now this entire equation is in the form
of an
in the in the form of integrations but
suppose
uh and and very importantly the physical
meaning of that is
this equation this balance of linear
momentum equation as written here
it can only be applied to an
overall volume okay you have to apply
this entire
this equation to a total volume
but suppose we want to write this
equation
locally that is that will be applicable
at a single point
what then how can we obtain an equation
from this volume integral fashion of the
or the integral fashion to uh to a
to a single point so that is referred to
as the local equation
how can you obtain such a local equation
well
the first step towards that end is to
actually
substitute this fraction vector in terms
of the sigma dot n
okay so
and you'll see in a moment why that
motivation is there
okay
so
we are proceeding with the motivation of
uh going from
the the integral form of the balance of
linear momentum
so what we say here is that
getting back
to the balance of linear momentum
equation
what we have here is the volume integral
rho
dv dt minus
the body force per unit mass
dv and on the right hand side we have
the surface integral
of the traction vector now we are going
to substitute
this thing here so we are going to
substitute this we have substituted this
sigma dot n
here now you see this is a surface
integral
and our motivation is to go from a
uh from a integral form to a local form
now suppose suppose you think
that in some way
okay this is our wish that we want to go
from the
integral form to the local form suppose
instead of
this being a surface integral suppose if
this were a volume integral
then what could we have done we could
have taken
this term also common here i repeat
suppose by some magic this where
a volume integral instead of a surface
integral then we could have
easily transpose this to the left hand
side and we could have taken
everything common under this one volume
integral
and then by arguing that
since this is a general balance equation
and
it must be true for any arbitrary volume
the only way that this thing is going to
be equal to 0 because
you know you understand that when i
transpose this to the left hand side
you'll be left with a 0 on the right
hand side
so the only way that this entire volume
integral is equal to 0
would be possible if the integrand is
equal to 0
and that's how we would extract a local
form but that is only a wish
we do not actually have a volume
integral here we only have a surface
integral
but by writing this fraction vector in
terms of this sigma dot
n we are one step towards moving to a
volume integral
and how is that well i'm sure you must
have all fit
i mean a lot of you must have figured
out that
we can go from this particular form of
the surface integral
to a volume integral using the gauss
divergence theorem
so
what we can do is rho
dv dt minus b so the left hand side
remains as it is
and on the right hand side what we'll
have is from this surface integral so
this
sigma dot n form
if we use the gauss divergence theorem
we'll obtain
the divergence of the sigma and that
will be the
volume integral so here we are using
the so let me write it below
using gauss divergence theorem
okay so the moment we have this
particular equation
we can go uh we can transpose this
what we were saying earlier that suppose
we had this volume integral by some
magic
so the magic is that we are using the
gauss divergence theorem
along with the cautious formula and from
here
we can simply transpose to the left hand
side
and write this as
minus delta dot
stress tensor integration over this
entire thing
dv is equal to 0
okay so let me go to the next
slide and continue so i'll write the
write the integration once again
rho dv dt
minus b i'm just repeating whatever i
wrote
just now dv
is equal to zero okay
so the argument that we that we invoke
in order to go from this volume integral
on to the local form is that
so because
this must be true
when i say this it basically means this
balance form
this balance form must be true
for any arbitrary volume
[Music]
we must have
the integrand itself
to be zero
okay so overall
this is more
commonly written in this particular form
rho dv dt
is equal to delta dot
sigma we just transpose the terms
two terms to the right hand side like
this so this is the more common form
and this particular form
this is referred to as
the very very famous hoshi's equation of
motion
this is extremely extremely important
okay i believe
that even in fluid mechanics you came
across this
equation okay and please note that till
now
we really have not said anything which
is specific
to solid mechanics like what the steps
that we have carried out
is perfectly true for any general
continuum mechanics
scenario whether it is fluid mechanics
or solid mechanics
later on as we keep on developing our
our theory and our framework we'll see
how it can be specialized to the study
of
solid mechanics but for now this is
absolutely true for any general
containment mechanics scenario
however uh for the purpose of
our mechanics of solid scores what
is more common to use is not this
cautious equation of
motion rather a certain specialized
version of it
where we say that
or static equilibrium
for static equilibrium we do not have
any acceleration term
you understand that the time derivative
here of the velocity is nothing but the
acceleration
so for static equilibrium
this term root dv dt
that is equal to zero and therefore
what we'll have is delta dot sigma
plus rho b is equal to 0
and what that basically means
in component form is
maybe i should use the next slide for
this
so what what this equation basically
means
uh this particular equation in component
form
is that
so this is the first component uh
so if some of you are having some doubt
regarding what components i am writing
here you please note
this equation and you try to understand
what is the tensorial order of this
if you are finding some difficulty with
this term
you can work it out in a slightly
indirect fashion
by noting that whatever the order here
must be
it must be consistent with the order of
the other term
because in a particular equation all the
different terms must be of the same
tensorial order
now this particular term is very easy to
understand it is just a scalar
multiplied by a vector
so this is a vector quantity more
mathematically speaking it is a
tensor of order one so no matter
what the actual form of this may be it
must
and must be a tensor of order one also
so overall it must also be a vector
and just like this vector quantity has
three components this one will also have
three components
and what we are writing here is
basically so this
these three terms together that is the
first component of this vector
and the row b1 you understand is the
first component of this vector
that is all there is to it so now we are
going to write the second component
so these are the these three terms are
the second component of this
vector quantity
again these three terms are the third
component of this vector quantity
and this is of course the third
component of the rho b vector
now you note that in writing these
equations
i have actually utilized the fact that
sigma 1 2 is equal to sigma 2
1 the sigma 1 2 that is written here it
is perfectly all right
but here i should have actually written
very strictly speaking sigma 2 1
but i am utilizing the fact that sigma 2
1 is equal to sigma 1 2.
similarly here this is perfectly all
right
but this one the sigma 2 3 that should
actually have been sigma 3 2
very strictly speaking but again i'm
utilizing the fact that sigma
2 3 is equal to sigma 3 2 and similarly
for this term also sigma 1
this should be sigma 3 1 strictly
speaking but i'm utilizing
sigma 3 1 is equal to sigma 1 3 okay
now these equations with either this
equation
in vectorial form or these three
equations together
they are referred to
together sorry about that
together they are referred to
as the
as the stress equilibrium equations okay
so either this
vectorial form or these three equations
together
they are referred to as the stress
equilibrium equations
and time and again all throughout this
mechanics of solids course
you will have the the necessity of
actually applying these equations even
in your
in your problem sheets and also in your
later chapters
all right
so uh in the
in the subsequent classes we'll continue
our discussions of
uh of the stress components uh but uh
but for now we'll uh we'll stop here
thank you very much